[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est l'avant dernière de l'année que je
suis heureux pour toi tu attendu l'avant
dernière de l'année pour refonder une
famille non mais c'est vrai pour
retrouver une famille et voilà mon chéri
tout va bien c'est avec vous ça va
marcher très beau ce petit d'homme merci
beaucoup s'est joué là comme ça alors
tout va bien barate c'était beau vous
faites très bien les gestes là prêt pour
le carnaval de rio
alors qu'est ce qui se passe est oui
alors depuis la semaine dernière
j'essaye de terminer ma chronique
il me reste un magnéto que je n'ai
toujours pas pu jouer alors qu'est-ce
que vous m'autorisez à la classe et pas
pour enfiler des perles
je vous en prendre une info médias que
vous êtes vous êtes le seul vous allez
me dire mais c'est pas possible
lui va m'apprendre une info médias sur
ces huit savez ce qui se passe la chaîne
prépare en retour prépare un retour en
secret une émission exceptionnelle
la nouvelle star c'est lui qu'on a
décroché depuis vous avez raison nous
attendait a demandé avant de lancer la
nouvelle star oui moi je vais vous dire
oui ou non mais non j'ai géré je me suis
pas faire ma chronique vous me troubler
la regardes et tu vas me dire tu
reconnais quelqu'un qu'est ce qu'il ya
c'est quoi ce bordel encore mais sacha
ces mamans bon avec serré l'ontt a fait
une belle rigolade
alors tu sais à quel point je vais dire
l'émission tous les soirs et je te
remercie à quel point tu me défends
aussi tous les soirs concernant le sujet
de guillaume genton mais je suis et je
reste quand même une grande fille je
sais me défendre
après il faut savoir que guillaume reste
quand même un beau garçon même si un
style à revoir ça reste quand même un
beau garçon en tous les cas je vous fais
tous un gros bisou à toute l'équipe à
cirer là tout les codes tous les
chroniqueurs et bien sûr à guillaume à
très bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors moi alors moi je vous dis madame
elbaz je craque
ah oui ça s'appelle madame commence pas
ça s'appelle caroline caroline je craque
elle est magnifique mais on le voit
c'est magnifique
guillaume les sublimes pas pro khaddi
non non il est entendu ce qu'elle a
démenti
valérie est ce que vous a demandé votre
elle est très jeune mais trop vieille
pour lui comment l'amour n'a pas d'âge
franchement est-ce que alors moi aussi
je vous savez quoi moi j'ai un truc que
je traîne depuis lundi parce que ce que
vous croyez que l'ue peut être mon
beau-père regard des escales à la
cadette nouveau pearl
[Applaudissements]
magnifique et sa maman qui l'a eu
complètement aller on ne sait plus ce
qu'on voulait faire
vous avez un petit mot du tout dans le
monde ces derniers mois c'est le
meilleur moment
je me sens la cuisse je vous apprends
dans l'info média qui concerne ses 8 et
oui vous n'êtes pas au courant tôt la
chaîne prépare en secret le retour d'une
émission que vous avez brillamment animé
et tué la nouvelle star j'ai dit non pas
du tout on a déjà dit moi je reprends
vous calmer par la famille l'attend pas
l'effort pardon fait pourtant pas c'est
qu'ils ne croient pas mais j'ai des
preuves de quoi j'ai des conversations
sms avec sa caméra vous aimez le tlm a
pas photo sacha plaisir partagé ça vous
dirait de 10 les jeudis soir lâche tout
cela band hero de la banda du semo avant
d'être une belle je suis une femme
des défauts
je vous précise que guillaume genton est
un grand producteur il a beaucoup de
graphistes qui travaille avec la vidéo
c'est mon cul je n'y crois pas ces
ladies fake là comme l'annoncé une vraie
vie des ossis avec elle à elle est très
parole khaled égal je crois pas ça je
vais je dire tu vas arriver le matin et
tu vas le voir au petit déj puisque
cyril me charrient va prendre un peu
cher regarder la nouvelle star ça arrive
sur ces 8 avec kerbadj a fait sens on
regarde s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
dieu
et
les [ __ ] cette chanson mon pote m'a
entendu deux cent mille fois on était au
karaoké de saint julien molin molette
[Musique]
when you un moment il ya une fausseté du
fait faire une descente d'organes
des plus grands chanteurs de douche que
j'ai jamais vu c'est à dire que tutu
occupe un espace qu'est autour de toi de
1 mètre carré
je sais
ben moi notre âme vente jusqu'à
l'intérieur de votre slip avec votre
bouche grande ouverte dans tu ne sais
vraiment pas bien vraiment c'est pas
bien pour moi c'est non les bras pleins
les yeux de castle on dirait même des
grains
vous souhaitez passer avec votre anus et
une technique du chant il faut avoir
il faut pousser et ouvrir son anus
[Applaudissements]
tu viens pour les meilleurs moments mais
demain à l'est par contre ma mère ça y
est c'est la tranquille quand même
attaqué au coeur de l'actualité de vos
qualités sentimentale de guillaume
genton aller ça lui chante et vite
et j'en sais avec votre anus noyer pas
[Applaudissements]